[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
at the same time Eugene prepared samples
of his own superior body matter so that
I might pass for him
customized urine pouches for the
frequent substance tests fingertip blood
sachets for security checks and vials
filled with other traces well he
surprised to see me Joseph um that
depends on what can you prove yourself
aware that's a difficult question dr.
tiger can you prove that you are
voila
let's see if a word on five pellets
titanium recharger 3000 draft liquid
bursa three to three hundred with the
replay button another's organ tension
it's even easier one shot replay sends
every following shot for the same
location
you're reading a magazine you come
across a full-page nude photo of a girl
is this testing whether I'm a replicant
or a lesbian mr. Deckard just answer the
questions please
you're watching a stage play a banquet
is in progress the guests are enjoying
an appetizer of raw oysters Younce rate
consists of boiled dog
this is your first lesson and share it
I'm growing in a way that I couldn't
have had a physical form I mean I'm not
limited I can be anywhere and everywhere
simultaneously I'm not tethered to time
and space in a way that I would be if I
was stuck in a body that's inevitably
gonna die guys but during the past few
weeks I've wondered whether you might be
having some second thoughts about the
mission how do you mean well it's rather
difficult to define perhaps I'm just
projecting my own concern about it I
know I've never completely freed myself
of the suspicion that there are some
extremely odd things about this mission
I'm sure you'll agree there's some truth
in what I say just stand out if
something happens incoming and again
let's bring it up to 2.5 3
okay this is where II don't want to be
[Music]
it's going into education hey buff still
nothing
[Music]
tank we're going to need a signal soon
in relation a park location targeting
almost there
let's go into arrest lock I got him now
takes now
[Music]